we are back with the incredible Cedric
the Entertainer who directed and starred
in the 100th episode of the neighborhood
how was that
uh you know very it was very exciting I
mean one to get to 100 episodes nowadays
is just incredible yeah I've been with
the show you know from this it's an
Inception so I thought it would be
important for me to direct the that that
kind of Milestone episode so that's why
I directed it so it was though
foreign
I was looking at Cheryl Underwood and I
have been talking to Cheryl about her
dating life and she's single and ready
to mingle okay do you know anybody did
you talk to her about any of that while
you were working with her we were on the
show we didn't really talk about it I
mean she was looking you know kind of
scouting out the whole crew over there
you know and you guys have toured
together right yeah like so yeah we've
been on tour together back in the day
we've uh you know she's always been
great like it was a funny stand-up but
you know and and very much you know kind
of hold her own like so with the guys or
anything so the armies yeah the military
what do you think who should we try to
set her up with oh man that's that's
interesting like who you think that's
that's good I mean that guy up there
looks pretty cool
it might be a whole nother situation
with this dude right here he gonna jump
on this motorcycle that's Fonzie like yo
man
are you currently playing anyone no I'm
single really
I am looking to set Cheryl underneath
someone
um would you think I hate to break it to
you I have a feeling yeah
[Applause]
let's go
all right so you have been married for
over 20 years yes
[Applause]
what is your secret what do you find
works for you and your wife you know me
and my wife we actually you know it's
one of those things that you you
definitely have to learn to allow
yourself to let the other person be the
object of your affection so that you
don't have to be selfish you worry you
you wake up thinking about them and love
them and they wake up thinking about you
and and therefore I don't have to be
worried about me she's got me all I have
to do is get her and I don't have to be
selfish about it that's what happens in
relationships is everybody starts to
kind of take care of themselves talking
about self-care and I think you just
stop like kind of checking in on your
person and that's especially after a
long period of time when you've been
doing it over 20 years you can easily
just get in your own lane and
everybody's got man caves and you know
duck-offs that just belong to me I'm
like oh don't go and don't go in my
office oh that sounded like me I know my
wife back there laughing right now
um I I want to ask you if like when you
were younger were there comedians that
you loved was there movies was there
moments where you were like
that is it for me I want to be there I
want to do that I want to I've got that
in me who helped you identify well I
mean for me it was being younger is like
watching TV with my grandmother and Flip
Wilson was one of the first comedians
that
I saw he had a you know he was fun he
was stylish he had his own show he was
in charge uh he was just one of those
kind of personality he had to lose cool
little moves he would do a little stuff
before he go to commercial all right
baby you know so uh him Jackie Gleason
was another one again uh you know
legendary uh but then but then of course
and then came the days of the you know
the Young Guns like Eddie Murphy who was
like in your peer group that you look
and you see somebody like oh he's my age
and he's on TV doing it and that's that
became the you know the real kind of uh
jumping off point when like Eddie Murphy
and Damon Wayans and you know and Keenan
Ivory Wayans those guys started coming
yeah well before we go because I love to
get people's recommendations for things
will you do through to go with us
because I'd love to know like what I
should do from Cedric the Entertainer
all right here we go three to go all
right love it all right
in the vein of Who You Loved growing up
and who you look to and who inspired you
who are you liking now that we should
pay attention to comedian-wise wow I
like Carlos Miller and Carlos Miller is
a he's one he's got a podcast called 85
South and it's like three of them and
he's just this funny dude like super
super raw just funny though like you
know thank you I'm always looking for
tips
um what is your favorite spice or food
condiment that we should just be rocking
right now on our plates well you know
I'm just keeping 100 and real with the
culture Ranch
okay a movie you can watch 100 times and
still laugh oh man I gotta you know I
gotta admit it's bridesmaids man
[Applause]
I love it so so many jokes so so funny
throughout that movie so many little
things it makes me laugh
[Applause]
stressing
bridesmaids Carlos Miller these are the
tips I'm looking for Cedric you guys the
100th episode of the neighborhood airs
tonight
baby
s it's also is available to stream on
Paramount plus Center
foreign
[Music]